I think we've got an Open Door situation
but
hello everyone and this is a grand
Masters Choice I'm Grandmaster Dennis
borosh and we are going to talk about
the Carlson era which we all know didn't
end yet emphasis on the yet because
we've got roughly
four or five days and Carlson is no
longer going to beat a world champion
he's just going to be like a dormant
volcano ready to erupt at any moment
as a world champion but for now we are
going to delve deep into some Carlson
era brilliencies now the first game that
I want to show is Anand versus MAC chain
and um even though we're talking calls
and error right we're talking about
Carlson being brilliant but actually
it's sort of an interaction between
Champions do we know who were the big
players of that time we're talking about
2011 12 13. were the big names
any ideas from that era tepalov
obviously was one of them because
um he became quite strong once Kasparov
departed of course Anonymous was one of
them as well in fact played a match not
even one but two matches against Magnus
carlsa
anyone else
on uh that time yeah
okay
this no no problems at all
um but we've got kramnik
laco so plenty of these players they're
very well known and they actually
influenced each other so even though the
games you you're going to see they're
not exactly the same and they're not
copycatting each other completely but
the direction is kind of very similar so
that is something I want to pinpoint so
that's uh delve deep this is the game
between Anand and McShane one of the top
Brit players of the time
um now we've got the stronger British
player of reason but there is a
legendary Brit player from the past
anyone know who it is
yeah so there are plenty of them
obviously
most recent of course is David Howell
but of course there is a bigger and more
famous One who actually played a match
against sparov
galphon gal fund is actually
representing Israel
the British Empire
so let me just actually catch up with
Chad here
or calls an era Brilliance is limited to
Carlson no it is anyone who was in the
era of Carlson obviously
um yeah
it's Groundhog Day I I highly doubt it
but I am making a return that is correct
so
short it's obviously sure to play the
match against Gary Kasparov but there
were plenty of very strong players
Spillman Tony miles and of course
you could not forget about Mickey Adams
always making plans for Nigel holy
all right so let's go ahead and
go
see what happened Maxine was actually a
very very good upcoming player
um he's sort of semi-professional at the
moment but was a big hopeful for Great
Britain D4 E6
okay so you guys had a lesson not long
ago about openings did you guys actually
get to have a bit of talk about the
concepts of openings what is sort of the
major goal in an opening
it of course goes for the live audience
and anyone just watching us right now so
what is something that you should be
looking for in a position such as this
one
you know you could classify as a closed
position
you want to control the center so we're
kind of doing a semi-good job you've got
one Pawn in the air in there but you got
to be greedy the more you have the
better it gets
well you do want to get your king into
safety but Anand was quick to do that
early on
so we castled we've got one Pawn in the
center oh that uh Mouse is getting
tricky but for now it's evening out
so you could go for C4 this is a very
standard oh if I can draw that Arrow
please
come on
I'll help oh now it's a blue one all
right I give up that that Arrow ain't
gonna happen but we can also go for E4
bricks so C4 is a standard idea and a
good one but uh
obviously E4 is a break now E4 doesn't
quite work yet because there's D take C4
and then we cry because it's undefended
so we've got to prepare that idea and
the question is how to do that
so C4 is completely natural and is a
normal move but here actually Ananda is
going for the E4 move which kind of
resonates to his normal unusual style of
going for E4 uh moves
and what's actually kind of fascinating
if you're interested into a little bit
of a tidbit
there's a reason why this she played
this opening while you can figure out a
way to make that E4 happen
so a long time ago there was a world
championship match between Vichy Anand
and Gary Kasparov
and Kasparov actually had plenty of
people helping him out including one
Jonathan Spillman who's also a fantastic
player and regularly played this system
as white
and if you don't know John Spillman he
was obviously a multiple time candidate
and was in the top of the field in the
80s 70s 80s
well if you go in id1 you do help the
idea but then you're sort of
self-pinning yourself here and that is
something you do not want to do
now do we like to capture pawns with our
Rook
no why not
if Noah is the answer
exactly the problem with rookie one and
the idea of going E4 that often times is
just going to become a weakness
so 92 is played you actually prefer to
have a knight on that square you want to
go here and then you want to go to E4
and F6 Rook E1 so you actually want to
use your Rook as a support but usually
from far far away so it cannot be
attacked
so rookie one Bishop E7 E4
so
there is the idea of basically getting
rid of the D5 Pawn if possible
so for that very reason if they trade
well we are happy with that because we
take take and white gets a nominal
Advantage with black actually not having
any Pawns in the middle while white has
a pawn there and a bit more development
so it actually gives a pleasant position
for white
I mean you could trade trade
Bishop G5 but this actually runs into a
splendid little idea
it's not absolutely hard to find but
it's a nice little twist here
that is this move of Pawn to D5
and white actually manages to put
pressure on Black's position
before black could comfortably Castle
so for that reason
black actually does not take on e4 and
castles himself
Pawn H3 Bishop H5
so there is actually a general problem
with these positions and that's the wide
squared Bishop the problem of the wide
squared Bishop is that if it's locked in
it can't move if you move with it you're
wasting time moving the bishop
so the question is whether we want to
take on F3
you're going to stop me from playing E5
well I can stop you we already played H3
but then you know maybe later we can
play E5
can I jump Knight E4
um there's reasons that you can't really
go on it4 black was on Castle so it
didn't quite work as well
I'm sure you could play Queen D3 the
problem is with Queen d3s if you go
Queen D3 you actually put your queen in
danger with ideas of Bishop F5 attacking
the D3 Queen so that's why you don't
move your queen out early and to Rook
out early because it's an easy target
so back to The Possession
why wouldn't we want to take on F3
it's actually fairly simple and
self-explanatory if you take on F3 well
white gets something black will never
get back
what is that
well that maybe but mostly you give up a
bishop
and now white gets two Bishops
and black doesn't have that so white
could get a position such as this one
it's still a nominal Advantage however
it's the bishop pair plus the center
so if you ever follow basic rules
rules of doretsky of two weaknesses
that's already a lot of leg up for white
you got the center plus the bishop pair
and now you can kind of understand first
the issue was that black had a bishop
locked in now the issue is you don't
have a bishop so this is how problems
compound in a position
the bishop H5 and you know we never
really praised the side
um who's not the hero of the day but
Bishop H5 is a great move by Mac chain
keeping the tension and keeping the
bishop on the board
C3 Bishop G6 E5 and the question is
where would you put your knight
E8
okay
why would you put the nine on E8
feels safer so going here
ah
okay just going over there
so he got an id4
and chess is always about deciding which
way you want to go would you want to
jump over here to the E4 Square
to the E4 square right there or to E8
one of the reasoning I kind of liked is
that the Knight on E8 is fairly safe
what could be the upside of having the
Knight on e4
it could get embarrassed on e4 possibly
although we do have a lot of Defenders
there like the bishop is defending the
pawn is defending this is not like black
is outright losing in that case
so the upside of playing Knight T4 is
that actually you get a strong Knight
the upside of 98 that is guaranteed
safety at 98 I think is probably a bit
more reasonable than I T4 Knight E4 is a
brave move
now the upside of 94 is if it's good
it's very good because you got a knight
in the center and your knight is not
passive on the E8 however because of the
nature of the position both of these are
very much playable as black is going to
go for C5 breaks later on and it's not
going to be game over anytime soon in
fact it's just a lot of maneuvering
ahead so even though the night on the
8th is passive and that's a downside so
normally you want to go forwards
but here you have the luxury to maneuver
it to a better Square to C7 for example
over here
but Maxine goes for an ID form and it
takes E4 and this is actually typical
super GM play they don't like if you
have a good piece they just say no no no
no I don't want to have a good piece I
don't want to stare at your good Beast
give it to me all right take C4 Bishop
takes E4 so our job here for why it will
be to eliminate the good pieces for our
opponent and then also of course come up
of a with a plan of Our Own
tonight E4 Knight F1 is also interesting
trying to play against this Knight but
I'll give you a bit of an advice okay
some of you are trying to lose the game
that's okay so others like to win as
well
rookie 4 is mathematically incorrect so
we're not going to talk about it not F1
well
truth be told we always hope to capture
the Knight on e4 but unfortunately the
Knight on e4 is very very difficult to
capture they usually play F6 and even
though there are Pawn Whispers that say
never play F6 this time they're
incorrect here you gotta go F6 and once
we trade this Knight is never going to
get captured by this Pawn push of F3
that's actually the main idea whenever
your opponent gets a knight in the
center and you still got some pawns to
chase it with
if F3 works it's beautiful but if it
doesn't well then you're just wasting
time
if you think about it you're misplacing
the night that was doing some job
attacking the Knight on e4 to a much
worse place on F1
so F6 is an idea just for the Knight to
escape
so Knight takes
Bishop takes
all right so so far so good
this actually might resemble for some of
you to some different openings
so if you look at this position what
does this position look like
and it's more like an E4 open uh well
it's not doing Justice to call it an
open but it's one of the e-force systems
that fisher loved the most so what do
you think what sort of opening does this
look like
yeah it has this Karo Khan feel to it
yes for sure
it does look a bit like a French because
of the structure obviously it's sort of
a mishmash of both
um
it's more of like a Caro it's a French
and it also have a bit of a slav if
we're looking from a different uh angle
and if we look at from a closed opening
perspective Okay so
if you kind of see this formation you
might be wondering
where our piece is in when I'm saying
our pieces are looking at where are the
white pieces staring at
what's the direction
that's what I'm trying to ask here
well
Center no this bishop isn't really
looking at the center You could argue
that with the Rook for sure
but what about the queen
well everywhere but you have to always
focus and decide where would the queen
have the most impact
is it the queen side
the side of the board are on the king
side
which side of the board would it have
more effect
yes the queen actually is poised
to join the attack and join The Fray
Over Here
sometimes in the long future like long
future
but first Anand says I don't want your
Bishop there
notice the tendency
Maxine created a nice Outpost for his
night and another said no no no no no no
no no no none of this thing
I don't want to see none of that
so Bishop G6 is also a nice move by Luke
he's saying okay I want to keep my
Bishop it's going to defend my king I
don't necessarily want to trade this
bishop
because this is a very much favorable
trade for white because this bishop
ain't doing too much good point there
Ahmed if we go Queen B3 there's Queen B6
and it's basically annulling each other
so you can't really do too much on the
clean side
now that's also a reasonable way of
thinking about Chess and thinking about
strategies you may look at an idea on
the queen side but then you say oops
well this sort of Peters out
okay
so our opponent moved the bishop away
but that might just give us some new
ideas
wow what the white wants to trade the
bishop and black doesn't well this
bishop is way more useful on this
diagonal and this bishop is just biting
Granite over here on G2 yeah what'd you
think sir
so it's actually a very interesting
question here
of
how to inconvenience Black's position
so you can always think and do the basic
I have this plan so I'm going to execute
my plan
that's not necessarily bad however
you could definitely respond to ideas
especially as uh black has been moving
that piece around for a long time now
yeah because you're almost trapping the
bishop right
yeah you just go H4 and you're setting
up the idea of H5 G4 F3 and you're sort
of pushing all the pawns for the bishop
so if they just go to do then that's
just gonna be game over because the
bishop runs out of the cascading Pawns
nothing you can do
total eclipse of a heart
there's nothing you can do there it's
over
so you always got to be vigilant and see
what your opponent is about to do there
it's H6 Bishop F1
guess why he goes to Bishop F1
and the reason is exactly because he
wants to go Bishop D3 trade this bishop
off and then I get to trade off my bad
Bishop for your good one
C5 Maxine is going for immediate counter
Play Bishop D3 take Stakes
and I would say that this she somewhat
succeeded because he's got the center
control got rid of a bishop that was
kind of useless and black no longer has
that great Bishop along that diagonal
however can we kind of claim white is
winning
yeah that is obviously not winning but
white has the firm control of the center
so white and chest terms we'd say is
just much more comfortable
okay so there's one thing to achieve a
position that's much more comfortable
but as far as I remember the game ends
when there's Checkmate on the board
gotta find a way we could come closer I
still understand how the light Square
Bishop is useless well it's useless like
how is this not useless the bishop isn't
doing anything because you're attacking
a pawn that you can never capture that's
how simple it is
so takes
and the question is
where should we be looking for an attack
now if there's anyone over here live
watching either
um at Chet or in person you may recall a
guy named
Bobby Fisher
if you recall Bobby Fisher and his games
against unseeker and many many of his
brilliances in the king's Indian attack
that may actually give you a hint what
vishi is about to do to Black's
possession
so that is definitely an idea now taking
here is a little bit early so if we take
that's
first off it's not our move but even if
we take take
we are not there yet with the attack we
need more pieces so there is always this
tendency because we solve so many
puzzles that oh it's this time to attack
you have to actually have enough pieces
to overwhelm your opponent
yeah Niger is a brilliant idea because
you want to involve your pieces as much
as possible
but okay let's continue with the game c
ticks black ticks Queen A5 so black kind
of realizes if I'm going to meander
around you may just attack me with
Knight G4 and uh it you know danger
danger is showing up
so Maxine is quick to take take Queen A5
now whenever we start out playing chess
one thing we always forget is that our
opponent is always trying to do
something naughty
so you can't just go on ig4 here because
oops that'd be a rook
so we gotta make sure that doesn't uh
happen
okay so there's one more question I do
want to answer why capture with the pawn
instead of the queen usually you want to
keep the pawn chain going because they
support each other if you take with the
queen well it's not necessarily bad but
the queen is a very bad piece to have an
outpost with because it's easily driven
away if you wouldn't have captured the
Knight I'd be saying that well maybe
that's an option because it's a good
blockading piece but a queen is a pretty
horrible one so instead I would take
with the pawn in here because the queen
is just not ideal
Queen A5
so you want to find a way and respond to
this
okay
any other ideas
all of these moves make perfect sense
but don't forget it's all about
thinking what the opponent might respond
to it
because Bishop D2 looks very very nice
on the surface however if you look one
move further of how black would respond
you'd be like nah I pass
foreign
but in general both moves respond to the
threat
Knight F3 makes sense however the
downside of Knight F3 that we actually
played Knight H2 a couple of moves ago
one of the things that's most important
in chess once you embark on a plan try
to finish that whole sequence
because if you go back and forth back
and forth you'll never know if your idea
ever worked in the first place
so what could be the issue with Bishop
D2
exactly so if we go Bishop D2 there's
Bishop B4 and we can move away with this
attacking piece which is important in
the attack because the E4 Rook is gonna
fall and after the trade black is more
or less fine
so this is seeing that this runs into
that idea goes and plays Bishop E3
just so he keeps the bishop there and
that's again the thing so I've got
suggestions here that Bishop C3 but
again you're sort of straying from the
original plan you want to stick to your
plan
so Bishop E3 sticking to the plan and
avoiding any sort of Trades with Bishop
B4
Rook C8 very nice move creating a little
bit of square the king may be able to
run away so this move even though seems
simple it makes so many options possible
for Mac Shane
Queen E2
actually preparing the idea of clean H5
Queen A6 trying to trade and we go say
no no thank you thank you for the
generous offer but no thank you
I mean G4 he goes King h8 which is sort
of the most natural move
but most natural or not maybe King f8 is
also an option
just trying to run away from danger but
in any case Maxine chooses to go king h8
in queen H5
so Queen H5
and there is a threat here on F7
now
black here plays the move King G8
thinking that everything is going to be
fine
unbeknownst to him he's going to be
wrong because he's not going to be fine
so here black has an amazing little move
that could have sort of changed the
whole direction of the game
and usually we don't look at these
moments but they're pivotal and I'm
going to explain to you why Max Shane
actually made this mistake I'm going to
call it a mistake however what Anon is
going to do is
quite outstanding to put a modeling
so
one has some threats
and the black sort of assumes well the
only way to defend is with defense but
that's not the only way Tom knows this
best defense
it's the counter attack
what could black play here
Queen D3
and what are you attacking
so when I say counter-attacking I mean
you're counter-attacking something the
idea of Queen D3 actually is pretty good
but for now there's a pawn a value
hanging so you can't just make a move
that's
looking good or a good looking move
F6 well
in general you don't want to move that
pawn especially as you move your Pieces
away so the difference between the F6 we
looked at earlier
and now
is that all of our pieces are on
vacation on Waikiki
just chilling on the clean side and then
trying to create weakness on the other
side that's always risky
Rook C2 is an idea
but in fact Bishop B4 is the strongest
why well if you go Rook C2 the issue is
I can take the pawn and I'm attacking
your Bishop
so
either you defend your opponent or
attack something of higher value
and Bishop B4 attacks The Rook which is
of a higher value
and the thing is if you go rookie two
now we have the move that we've already
gotten suggested
brilliant move
and there's a difference now note that
the Rook is no longer on E to E1 but on
E2
so there is the Strategic moves you guys
already mentioned this is very strong
now
and um I will explain that so the little
detail that could have changed sort of
the outcome of this game
well not necessarily the outcome of the
game but it would have been much more
balanced for sure
and what if I take the pawn
exactly
so Queen D3
you go here
up
then I can take this
so
if you go Rook C1 well all of our pieces
are eyeing the king side
come on draw that Arrow draw that come
on come on
yes success success so all of White's
pieces are aiming at the attack so if
you move your pieces towards the queen
side you're sort of admitting the defeat
you're strategically losing
you're losing the threat of the game
rokitu is sort of the most stubborn but
then Queen D3 and you can't really just
take the pawn because the Rook is going
to be hanging so Bishop Beaver is a very
hard move to spot because it's somewhat
of an absurdist move
I'm actually his next move is logical
King G8 and it seems like everything's
fine
probably Maxine thought well you're
going to sacrifice here
Pawn takes Knight G4 and you assume
you're going to break through but nah ah
I play Bishop f8
however Here Comes this year's genius
idea now I know many of you on the
internet you see double X clamps all the
time but those double X Clan don't mean
nothing
this move is a double X clamp and I will
explain but I'll give you guys the
chance
to find it
a double X clamp is usually a move that
does not make a lot of sense at first
blink but then you realize
if I would have thought of this I'd be a
genius
and if you thought of that you're
probably Vishing up
so what you kind of assume that McShane
looked at all of this and he probably
did but his next move by which he was
probably missed by him completely
now they are basics in chess that you
need to know can we check maybe the lone
Queen
is it possible
no it's not possible or in very rare
cases but most of the time alone Queen
can Checkmate unless it's back rank or
something of that nature
so you gotta have some pieces flowing
and helping out the queen so I can
deliver Checkmate you can take the Palm
however the downside of taking the pawn
is that you run out of pieces
and once you don't have enough pieces
you're never ever going to win this game
in fact you could play our favorite move
Queen D3 and it is Tata time for white
because the queen comes back in the
naked time and it's over
um
yes
brilliant brilliant move
by vishi so the thing is
in this position is that you kind of
look for the straightforward move you
look for the captures denied F6 right
that's what you look for you look for
this takes takes but then you can
Checkmate because the only Square you
can made is on G7 but that square is
covered by the bishop
the whole point of rookie three
is that Vichy is not only still
threatening these ideas but brings in a
new piece
it is a rook lift
he's lift and bro
Rook C4 Rook D1 not even giving up the
palm
Queen B6 Rook F3
so one of the threats is to take on F7
but that's not the only threat
so let's say
black
passes
I can just take here and take everything
so it takes
takes takes
Rook takes F7
and now I have this thread
this threat and there's not much you can
do but wait a second so there's one more
thing that I want to point out so here I
go here
here
here and now we have to find the one
obviously because whenever you sacrifice
you have to prove your point
so here the question is how white is
going to break through
before we look at the finishing touches
by vishi this is important
because if this fails the whole concept
fails
where there's many night checks might
have
okay I capture
I hide my king
so it feels like we don't have quite
enough attackers right
if we could magically get our Queen to
G7 that'd be wonderful but we don't get
there
right so you gotta look for a different
one
how does that help us with the attack
if we go Rook D1
but why do we need to bring the first
Strokes down
um
can I capture
Bishop
and I go here
and you just go through with the attack
yes look at four
and then the attack breaks through now
there's also a spectacular way of
winning you can check here and this
one's very beautiful this white to move
and you can set up a mating pattern
that's Unstoppable
and this one is somewhat related to
those Knight F6 ideas that we looked at
earlier some of someone in the chat did
mention the Fisher Banco now that's a
good uh starting point for this puzzle
over here
okay H5 looks good but you've got to
move that lens immediately
I capture
where does the rock move
mm-hmm
H5
and then we yeah that's it and that's
checkmate
very nice
so that's actually one of the reasons
you should look up the legendary games
including Fisher Banco that you kind of
will recall all these wonderful tactical
ideas
and this one is for the tactics books
and of course if you don't take then
Rook H6 is Checkmate bless you
so takes takes and you can't run you
cannot hide it's Checkmate in either
case
so sadly for Mac Shane after this very
very subtle little move it's just game
over
and this is the Mover that I consider
double X Glam or a brilliant move a move
that just stuns you because you don't
kind of anticipate that a slow burner a
slower a maneuver of a rook lift like
this could be a winner idea here
all these other double X clamps that all
game analysis give you that doesn't
really tell you the truth this is the
truth
so here Rook D1 only goes Rook D1
because once to over defend the D4 Pawn
Rook F3
Rook takes takes Queen G6 is very strong
I mean G4 then it's basically of
desperation because if you go Bishop G7
I can just simply when
how do we win easy
we've got Min and three
take your time you'll find it
take your time
one of them either Knight F6 or not H6
the queen Jesus I'm not telling you you
have to find it yourself
I'm here
to be the one who's the devil's advocate
here you're the one finding the moves
it's made in three
and obviously that's the reason Maxine
man for a second option although that
didn't quite change
okay then I capture you got two moves so
takes takes
now the next move has to be made
yep that's rough
whenever it's made in three it usually
is
just a quick sequence of checks in this
over
bam
check
and whatever you do you block you don't
block don't matter it's checkmate
if you go here it's Checkmate again
and look at that Rook again
just swiftly tucked in the garage doing
nothing
that's why you hurry up and double up
your pieces
so yeah
um of course Knight H6 Queen G4 this is
a Desperado but it doesn't change
anything
uh takes here because it stops the king
from capturing The Rook for free
this is a decisive Advantage for Vichy
he's got the extra lady and he's not
gonna mess it up and there's gonna be a
new princess coming
and that actually spells the end of the
game and as vishi is about to get a new
one Maxine decides it's game over I
don't want to fight this no more
no thank you I don't want none of this
anymore
okay so this was a nice little game so
well then
let's get it into the Magnus Carlsen one
so it's a Magnus ERA this is sort of the
Twilight for Magnus Carlsen as a world
champion
in a couple of days a week he's no
longer going to be a world champion
however he is still the one who had the
most influence on the players I think it
is just fair to call it his era
now this ain't going to be the same game
the same opening but just because the
opening is not the same does not mean
that the themes can be very similar
so
let's dig in D4
Knight F3 G3 something that we may have
seen in the world championship matches I
don't know if you guys followed
cousins matches but he did play this
plenty full times even before the world
championships with quite good results
now he was also influenced by Juan
Vladimir kramnik who had a brilliant
match again garricks against Gary
Kasparov but he was successful with the
Catalan much later as well
so anyone can tell me who he played this
G3 systems in his world championship
match against
any ideas
exactly it's Napo miyachi he played it
against napomniachi and actually with
great success in fact the critical game
six was decided and basically was the
decider that was
um going back and forth so it wasn't the
crystal clear game but it actually uh
decided that whole match
so Bishop B4 check A5 it's one specific
line
uh played by the kuang Liam
a very very strong Vietnamese super
Grand Master
in fact the player players who has won
Dortmund and uh I believe the aeroflot
opened twice back to back which was one
of the biggest opens at that time
A3 Bishop E7
okay so we look at this position and you
may again wonder you may not be familiar
with the basic details but that does not
necessarily matter if you know the
principles of Chess right
you know the basic principles you know
literally everything
I mean not everything but at least you
know enough to play the position
so what will be the main goal for white
which Square
should white occupy and that would make
Magnus really really happy
they forced Fair exactly
see Google screen C2
Knight D7 Bishop F4 C6 so how can we try
to Corral that square
yeah E4 is the square but for the moment
it is pretty much occupied by Liam
squares
I mean pieces he's occupying the E4
Square
Knight D2 or Knight C3 both is
completely sound
both of these ideas are good he goes for
castles and now he goes for Knight C3
this actually entails upon sacrifice but
he could have tried that Knight D2
that's also very natural and the whole
point would be is to get E4 in and this
again would give white a slight pull not
a decisive Advantage but white is pretty
comfortable
but he chooses Knight to C3
dtech Queen A5
E4 so he gets the center now if we're
playing Black here which move would we
choose would we take the E4 Pawn
would we take the C4 Pawn
you take the E4 Pawn anyone for the C
Pawn
well three pawns can taste good
so if you take on e4 you do make a fair
trade however D takes at least would
give you that extra Pawn to bank on and
give some chances for black however it
is of course compensation for white as
white has two Pawns in the middle and
black has none
you got the center control and that will
compensate even though these pawns also
not the best because they're doubled
so Rook D1
Rook E8
Okay so we've seen something similar
if you look at this game there will be
some resemblance between this one and a
game played by Anand
so you should
find the connections there connect the
dots
and you'll be happy
yeah you go rookie one but I'm very
happy of the E5 suggestion that is the
direction so white does not really care
that much of
taking control of the D5 Square he is
going for the attack
shocker I know
absolute shocker 95
here H4 Knight G6 first he goes Knight
E5
but he does go for the idea of E5 now
and the whole point is he's cutting the
board in half
and again just like in the previous game
black speed says Rock Queen Bishop is
completely sidelined and is not
participating in the defense
so Knight D5
we don't want the trade why don't we
want the trade
well we are on the attack we are down
upon we got to do something talking
about doing something what will be the
direction of our play
King said but we got to be concrete so
it's good that we have like a general
concept but then we have to back it up
with evidence
of how we're going to break through or
what will be the move that kind of makes
Black's position a little bit more
uncomfortable
foreign
go after the G6 Square it's over
defended by The Pawn on F7
so of course we love sacrifices but
sometimes it's not all about sacrificing
sometimes it's just a classic brilliance
you know bring up Asian Greek history
you want to have
some Greek techniques a trojan horse to
break through and RAM through
well this g61 indeed is the potential
Target but how can we undermine that one
bit H5 right
so how do we prepare that H5 push well
G4 you don't really want to push your
Pawn if you don't have to
so you would rather support that idea of
at pieces
H5 although Bishop F3 would be fine as
well
it goes for the immediate one
we need two and now he goes G4 I thought
he would go Bishop F3
and this would make absolute sense as
well
and it would also give him the option of
moving the king up now he uses a
different technique
G4
H4
takes B4
okay now he goes Queen F3 B takes
and goes Knight F6 check
ticks Bishop takes
a b so it feels like we're burning quite
a big bridge over there on that other
side right like everything is Fallen
there everything
but
then we have to kind of wonder what is
Magnus banking on what is his long-term
plan
uh-huh
indeed he's going to go for that in HD
Bishop G7 Bishop E4
okay but what's the idea of this one
and we are almost at the pivotal moment
we have to know what white is doing
that's why it's going with this bishop
E4 idea
it's pretty straightforward actually
a rook move yes so where is The Rook
going
the plan is to go King G2 Rook H1
so let's say I go here
here
I queen yay Queen
indeed Queen to h a check take
bye bye you may have 95 Queens on the
other side but they don't really matter
it's just checkmate
so Bishop E4 Queen B5 G5 just fixing the
structure
Queen B3 do we trade no no trade if
you're going for the win Bishop B7
King G2 C5
and this is the last critical moment
but here we have to be precise
and it really kind of is based on what
your opponent is trying to do you're
just trying to sabotage that
black is clearly trying to take this
bishop on e4 he manages he's happy
D5 yep and if Bishop D5 then what
happens
it's fairly straightforward you nope
gotta be more aggro
you gotta go hand it to gotta go
yeah
boom
and we give away everything
and it's mate
very very nice
so D5 e takes and of course here comes
the decisive Rook H1 and it's game over
can't do anything
you can't even take here because I'm
just going to capture with the Jeep on
so you have absolutely no play and that
mate isn't coming
um the whole point of G5 was so you can
capture with the g-pawn
so here then you can take this way and
he's going for zero to no counter play
for Liam
all right so I really hope all of you
enjoyed uh these games
played in the Magnus era all these
brilliancies and do buckle up because in
the future I will be Grandmaster in
Residence and hope to see you all in the
future as well so thank you so much for
tuning in
and hope to see you all next time as
well bye-bye
[Music]
foreign